yeah went welcome to this video
Kling beyond n from Brazil age six aha
okay probably a student of whichever
port we need g5 stuff yeah it's not that
bad actually I'll just try in the center
centralizing most should be four
[Music]
Dunaway don't quite understand what the
bishop moves to I just I just continue
with normal moves
you
okay
probably just night at six or something
or queen g7 I really don't know black
position is it's really somewhat
somewhat weird okay
you
[Music]
so okay
me now I'm probably threatening to take
on c5 and grab the pawn or does he have
something there like perpetual like with
the night anyway I can also just send it
back that is just really not having a
good position okay so I can go d5 and
like f4 something that there's nothing
wrong with just developing and see what
is up - okay
[Music]
[Music]
they're just 94 at 4mm f1 so there could
be some Nyjah for stuff that doesn't
really work probably it is not easy to
handle okay
yeah 93 I wonder what the best way to
play is here Bishop c12 something that
could make sense and just to try to
attack this pawn and get this over to
defend
he takes a long while now what is he up
to like 90 for something no okay yeah I
was thinking about Bishop c1 just get
this 93 is always extremely annoying him
yeah I like the sort of this would give
me some stability yeah dude this now
must be must be very nice my king is
totally safe and I mean strategically
speaking blacks position is just wreck a
complete wreck you either get something
quickly or you're just toast it's an
interesting move though it's one of
those get something quickly ideas now
can you open sea open stuff okay now
tries to do to something there on the
edge from
to do this and it could trade with the
night move night a for something is it
is snowing or this and I'm gonna have to
trade let's trade the special
while we never never picks up PCM
okay so Queen afire furs is on the cards
when it's extremely extremely dangerous
but I mean he he has the bishop almost
trapped after Queen f5 so it doesn't
play it here I can take a seven they
have night a four okay so if I do this I
will get the Queen's trade or this but
this is better
Knight b6 so check King e8 or this to to
to to to give the exchange it should be
quite good time warning no my king is
save and I can take myself check
[Music]
[Music]
butchy for let's step on this okay I can
take h4 hmm okay we are doing this way
all right here check time to make a
mistake
check check check check check check make
almost a minute in there that was close
oh okay
yeah it was really weird opening yeah
this g5 stuff has been played by to
report but I'm really not sure I have
this version because I like h6 is not a
move that you need there if you
absolutely insist on playing g5 you can
do it now and play Bishop g7 X you don't
need to go age six okay I have a hard
time to believe in this tremendous this
must be good for wild yeah D takes e5 I
thought about it briefly that I wanted
to play simpler yeah it looks good on
Bishop III in particular
now this isn't all that clear I thought
it looks wrong but I'm just just too
conservative I think sometimes yeah
jaren to 700 probably does not work but
it is it's tricky
who takes h4 was the threat so I had to
go out of this yeah yeah engine thinks
that white is better
it's so not easy to play yeah and he I
should win there were probably some
somebody and some things going on now
yeah I loved a bit too much them 5.now
wasn't all that clear
and she had better I mean okay with both
sides having no time on the clock it's
it's tricky
I was a nice one because my kids made
yeah turn share this one the Queen but
okay seven seconds against eight seconds
still not so easy okay guys thanks for
watching